Trump against DeSantis okay Trump has
already poked a couple times the
sentences came up and said look I'm
gonna let my record do the talking for
me uh he won by thirty four thousand I
won by one and a half million we're
winning Miami day and all this other
stuff trying to say that a lot of people
are talking about me every morning I
wake up how do you view this yourself
from Trump against DeSantis Trump is
okay with Nikki Haley running because
she may make a good vice president
candidate one day possibly but there
seems to be a little bit of a discomfort
with DeSantis how do you process that
well first of all what Trump said is
true uh Ron Sanchez does always owe his
rise in American politics to Donald
Trump 67 of 67 Republican County
chairman in this state endorsed Adam
Putnam for governor the agriculture
commissioner every single Republican in
the state legislature including the
Senate President and the house Speaker
indoor stat and Putnam every member of
the Congressional Delegation with the
exception of Matt Gates and Putnam was
far ahead in both money and the polls it
is only the tweeted endorsement of
Donald Trump that turbo charges the
candidacy of Ron DeSantis so I think the
president feels uh The Descent is now
challenging him particularly after Trump
had to come here uh in the 2018 election
and essentially dragged DeSantis over
the Finish Line won by 30 000 votes
um he does see it as a personal Act of
treachery as an act of disloyalty and
he's unhappy about it and Donald Trump's
never shy about telling you how he feels
about things
um the other point people Miss assured
Sanchez did win but Donald Trump got 1.2
million more voters in Florida in 2020
than to Santa Scott in the most recent
election so I do think there's going to
be a contest but I think the reason that
Trump seems to be propping Nikki Haley
up is Trump is probably sitting at a
base in the party which is very intense
of somewhere around 45 48 percent of the
vote there's another 20 percent that he
could get but his hard base is somewhere
between 40 and 50. and then a
multi-candidate field he's in much
stronger shape in a one-on-one race you
know the scientists in all honesty is
untested as a presidential candidate uh
is how big of a difference is that so so
for example for somebody to be a a a a
very very good candidate as a governor
who during covet he did very well and
you remember when the feedback that I
think Obama got from Emmanuel where he
says look you're not going to get a lot
of chances to be as on fire as you are
today you gotta run even though
everybody was telling Obama not to run
after the DNC speech all the he was on
fire he says you're not going to get
this again you got to run I am sure the
similar type of Rahm emanuels of the
right who are more the scientists are
saying you're not going to be hotter
than you are today the between now and
four years from now a lot could change
you have to run how do you address that
that he is the most hottest Governor yet
the difference between being a governor
president what's the big difference I I
see why he's doing what he's doing I'm
not I'm not defending it because I think
he could afford to wait but I also must
tell you that he's untested at this
level I mean he does very well in
Florida but that's where you control the
microphone he doesn't do well in a in a
wide-ranging uh
uncontrolled atmosphere particularly
when it comes to interviews uh you very
rarely see him smile he doesn't he does
not seem to like people he seems to me
to be an introvert in an extroverted
business potentially and how he's going
to wear as a candidate mixing with the
pig farmers in Iowa uh or the guys who
grow maple syrup you know in in New
Hampshire that remains to be seen I also
think that it's kind of early I mean I
think he said it's high water mark right
now it's very early to Peak this
election as you pointed out early 22
months ago a training month attorneys
always from now and also people are
going to be going to want to go back and
look at the record so he said for
example he would ban the teaching of CRT
in schools in Florida well right here in
Broward County they have just adopted a
curriculum from the ADL which includes
the teaching of CRT and there's 13 other
counties so he's got a lot of pledges
that were very popular in Maga world
that he made at the end of the last
election and he's going to be held to
those and I I think it's so therefore
it's not necessarily clear sailing he is
going to run we talked about it here
last time I was here as a matter of fact
he is going to run but you're getting in
the cage match you know with a very
tough guy and I still think at the end
of the day Trump would would defeat him
to see what Megyn Kelly said
did you hear what Megan Kelly said Megan
Kelly said there's no way the scientists
can beat Trump he says Trump's only
going to need 30 percent and his Maga
crowd alone that 30 is a lock
she said it's not even a good
opportunity for DeSantis to run I'm
paraphrasing what she said about this
and I said but okay let's just say you
do run the santis and let's say you do
be Trump actually go there that you do
be Trump
what is Trump going to do is Trump going
to say okay Maga crowd go and vote for
DeSantis that's the point she made and
then the second thing she said which is
a very very valid point as well as the
final one
what what is the likelihood
of trump say he loses let's say 10
chance 20 chance whatever the number
everybody is saying he loses to the
centers okay and now DeSantis is the
Republican nominee
what is the likelihood that the center
is Trump in a situation like that says
oh really that's what you guys want to
do no problem I'm going to run as a
third party yep oh I think that I think
he would do it what's the likelihood of
him doing very very very unlikely
unlikely unlike okay because of the uh
because of the enormous legal barriers
to getting on the ballot in 50 states
legal and financial barriers remember
we're not talking about a third party
candidate you're not the party of the
Liberty you're not the candidate of the
libertarian party or the green party so
it's an extremely expensive legally
extraordinarily complicated uh and
difficult thing to just get on the
ballot and if you have participated in
the Republican nominating process and
let's just say hypothetically you're not
successful well the deadline surpassed
for you to also compete as an
independent because they pretty much by
and large have the same deadlines
remember this ballot access all election
laws
are written by Republicans and Democrats
working together against any kind of
competition both extra party and intra
party so uh Trump could Bluff I guess
and he's done it in the past but uh why
would he leave the Republican Party he
is uh he's transformed the party into
the party of Working Class People
um I think she I think Megyn Kelly
understates the level of his support but
what she doesn't understate is the
intensity of his support Trump
supporters are not voting for anyone
else but the other thing about Trump
though as a candidate is he has makes a
lot of people go out and vote against
him just like he has the devotion of the
people that are part of his crowd he's
also very good at basically having
people vote against him he's very
polarizing yes just like say or I don't
know uh Joe Biden yeah big time okay so
if you enjoyed this club you want to see
another one click here to watch another
clip and if you want to take advantage
the latest gold Signature Series
products that just came out we have a
bunch of new merch that's out this is a
color change engine mug when you drink
coffee that lion turns into a real lion
and then we have hoodies with vitamin
gold on it the gold Signature Series hat
shirts I'm an entrepreneur anyways we
have a lot of items they're selling out
if you want to take advantage the gold
Signature Series click here place your
order Sports your right taming gear and
tag us with the hashtag valutamin
[Music]